we've been making imax films for the
last 35 years
many of them in conservation we always
wanted to do a film on the arctic the
beautiful images
and the wildlife she loves polar bears
when she sees a polar bear on tv
she just gets so happy i love them
there's nothing cuter than a polar bear
polar bears cannot thrive anywhere else
at home here and only here meryl
streep's voice
meryl streep is one of my heroes i
needed a
narrator who was a woman and a mother
she's just the perfect choice
people are going to love this narration
to photograph these
reluctant film stars john downer uses
clever robotic cameras camouflaged in
white
these cameras and the technology it's
amazing what they can capture on film
in 3d so it's the closest we're ever
going to get to seeing it
surreal settings that you wouldn't think
exists but actually do in nature so it's
great to be able to see that without
having to travel there you'll get a
sense of what it's really like
up there without having to be in the
cold you love it you know you basically
are out there with nature
seeing stuff that no one else has ever
seen before we wanted to
educate the public about what was going
on in the arctic how it is changing
rapidly
inspire people to emotionally connect
to the wildlife and the arctic and get
them so that when they get out of the
theater they want to do something and
this is the perfect
first event for little hank to go to
it's a great thing to do with the family
on a sunday
for us to be able to educate kids at
such an early age
i think that's one of the best ways
through this platform of imax theaters
and museums science centers and
aquariums around the world
to actually potentially create change
you